hey guys and Justina this is joey
graceffa hi there we are about to make
some Call of Duty cupcakes things called
duty ghosts just came out you don't like
all duty um when I'm over your house I
do exactly it was a long time ago along
that was black ops um one where we had a
zombie party the new ghost is out and I
like cupcakes and a lot of you guys want
to be make some cupcakes we're gonna
make some calls Duty goes cupcakes we
preheat the oven because Jodi told me
cuz I'm here that's why I maybe need
three large eggs
we're gonna make it a blender of course
no way oh and this is why use your right
just pour it in this is the devil the
devil spoon then it was moist so a lot
more 3/8 yeah one she thought your
fridge open it here we go for the Sun
yeah yeah yeah that's how we do it we
need a cup of water okay I'm on it
do it here we go this is a cover yeah
okay then we need a vegetable you know
this is gonna be the most successful
cooking video I may have ever done it's
really simple
yeah well so is pizza talk to them do
did it good night
why is the oil give me my stuff
get that oil up and there that's it I
guess so it was really simple real easy
it's a three-step process this let's see
me blend and Mark a girl oh my gosh and
one day usually
actually does look really good there's a
special Thanksgiving video we just did
for Jimmy's channel let's just say this
is definitely a treat that we needed
success is not
great okay now I once read making what's
called um Reese's Cups I use these and
part of it was to put it in my cup a no
and then third it's no children
that you're not supposed to put metal in
the microwave no metal in the microwave
for our toppings you have a rich and
creamy chocolate frosting mm-hmm or we
have buff Goldman's or Duff golden duck
you know he is yeah really
he's the cake guy kick pot okay guys
best thing you've ever tasted but we're
going to use him yeah yeah I know you'll
be a mess how many minutes how many
cupcakes hmm let's jump for like 15 all
right you'll be back
yeah minute okay look at this they're
doing they're doing something Joey like
there were starting race really really
soil it's kind of boiling is that bad
what is boiling have you ever done you
think
yes been two minutes yes it's really
been time no it's cause we set over 2000
AA balloons thank you look good
mm-hmm these things are really puffy my
cupcakes are usually flat I know is that
kind of like
oh yeah muffin I don't actually ever
made cupcakes before of you yeah oh is
this normal
I think they're supposed to be level
with the thing that's what I can do but
they're breathing in there on time you
know I'm not gonna wait for these are
cool we're just decorating right off
uh-huh
right is that this fun right yes you're
so big
okay so I think we've got some things
brewing here in the oven and it's not a
baby but I just chocolate cupcakes
should we stab them with a fork
definitely doesn't even do if it can get
that sticks it afford it's not ready not
right yeah okay it's ready yeah these
look perfect they actually look pretty
good yeah shoot if they're all the way
okay
holy crap is really is seeking through
the second layer yeah
perfect I'll just make it like a little
nice little nice little poo topping oh
my gosh it is melting right off I was
like we're not waiting we're just we're
just icing these up oh okay I don't know
what this really looks like it's always
gonna make school so there's a Call of
Duty ghosts logo okay do you want like
maybe like soon
there were we have fun pretty much look
at it check this out
it screams call of duty it really does
kind of looks like a cow babies put this
little chocolate right down the middle
oh you're looking good thank you it's
all about just trying your best
that's right oh it looks like a big poo
a massive poo I'm gonna go for a grassy
looking one Hey had a lot more potential
oh my god it looks so cool it actually
does look really good
okay it matches my goody yeah we're just
Ingo I don't know she kidding the bush
is what she did yeah I know can't even
see her well yeah I don't know I'm gonna
make another school one just because we
need about that measuring life here hmm
yeah what do you see we got actually
yeah he even told me to preheat the oven
in the beginning I like the jungle one
all right well my battery down on my
other camera but that's okay because
we're just gonna finish these up here
maybe we'll just do one more unless you
really I'm just you take this one and
understand dunk it right in there girl
like a dunkaroo yeah so I think that's
it
should we show them our masterpiece I
think that's it
I think my head was cut out the whole
time from this camera wasn't that ball I
face was puffing oh yeah look how great
their look always thanks for watching
make sure you check out Joey's channel I
will link the description and probably
an annotation is somewhere where's it
gonna be I don't know you tell us you
want uh distractions distractions
distractions distractions
show them instructions to make this we
don't have any more box yeah see you
later let us know if we should maybe
make something else one day Joey's gonna
be posting a video of us doing a blender
challenge during Thanksgiving look out
for that woman stay tuned it's in like
the microphone oh shoot
okay I didn't know stop it now oh no
it's oily yeah
Israel I mean you got your midst